All right. Did Zach and Rich get on, by the way? I've only
seen Craig. No, we only have Councilmember Whiting so
We do have a quorum. Yeah, we have a quorum, so we can proceed.
Okay. So I'm going to start before we go on with the prayer, and then
Councilmember Wright will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Our Father in Heaven, we're grateful to be gathered today to conduct city business
in this special council meeting, and we're grateful for all of our good citizens and
those that we strive to help and to make
this city a great place for all to live. We're grateful for all of our
staff and all those who support us and help us in the things that we
need and continue to do their best to help
us and provide those needs in a good manner and with a good attitude.
We're grateful for all of our blessings and the chance to
work together and ask that we will be able to conduct this business
with a good spirit and to always
be kind to others and to remember to assume good intentions.
And we say this in the name of Jesus Christ, amen. Amen.
Councilman Bright. Uh,
yeah, so we'll officially call this meeting to order at 3:32,
and, uh, Councilmember Wright will lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
I pledge
All right, welcome. We did call the meeting to order already, but it is August
10th and we're in a special council meeting. We have present online
Councilmember Whiting and Councilmember Hewish,
and in person here Councilmember Wright, Councilmember Clark, and myself
with some staff members. So I
just Uh, first item,
and I do— and Kiara is also online. So the first item is a resolution
of Eagle Mountain City, Utah, approving the fiscal year 2026 Community Development
Block Grant, CDBG, annual action plan and authorizing
its submission to the US Department of Housing and Urban Development. I do
know that there's like 4 slides, and we'll turn it to Kiara.
Uh, thank you, Mayor, and thank you, Council, and everybody who
carved out time for this special meeting. Um, I know you're busy. I am going
to do my best to make this fairly brief.
Um, let me share my screen.
Okay.
Alrighty, so we are going over the Community Development Block
Grant. Um, as we've mentioned in previous meetings,
We have a 5-year plan which goes through 2028,
and we are currently in year 3. Every year
we have to send a consolidated plan to HUD for
approval, and so that's what we are working to do today.
Just going over entitlement funds, so the CDBG
is available for targeted households that
are below 80%. We get those funds from HUD.
And these are the limits per household,
and those are updated annually as well.
Um, so the big item here that we're here to review— so ultimately
we would love, um, council approval
on these funding buckets that we have here. So we've allocated,
um, as you see, we have the guaranteed, the, um,
automatic 15% and 20% for public service and administration.
Those are caps that are set by HUD. Um, we We have allocated
$200,000 to housing preservation and/or development.
That can be fairly flexible. Uh, we don't have to, you know,
we're not zoning in on projects specific right now. We're just simply
wanting to allocate funds to these buckets that you
see here. Um, this is
just a little bit of a breakdown for how we are looking to potentially utilize
funds. Again, that's not anything that's been solidified right now.
Um, we have our administration and public services.
We already have our utility assistance that's been going and it's going great.
We do have housing preservation and development, nothing that's
been spelled out right now, but we have had some conversations around
maybe down payment assistance or home revitalization.
Again, nothing that's been carved out specifically yet.
And then as far as public facilities, And neighborhood improvements,
we've talked with departments about ADA and sidewalk upgrades,
maybe some senior improvements. We did have a public comment regarding school
community resource center, and so we're working to learn
more about that and any other eligible activities as well.
And so this fulfills our public hearing we've
had open for discussion. So now we are just looking to
Adopt and submit to HUD, um, the items
that you've seen previously. And that is
all I have. So,
Kira, just for a clarification, that first slide— it's okay,
it's gone now. Um, you can pull
it back up. The— in the past, we have paid,
um, MAG to do that, that 20% or that
$39,000 roughly, and we're now currently keeping that
in-house and you're managing that, correct?
We are working through some transition, and this is a great— actually great to
bring up. So we're— while it is coming in-house,
we have substantial items that we've needed to
clean up with HUD that's taken— so we're kind of in the middle of,
you know, going into new project year but also cleaning up and becoming compliant
with a lot of items in previous years. And so Elizabeth
has come in to help with some of that heavy lift that I've I'm
just not equipped to dig into with the amount of stuff that we've had kicked
back. Um, right now she is— we're
contracting with Elizabeth for our CDBG services out of our administrative
fund. If we wanted to keep that ongoing, um, as you've
seen, we have that 5-year in 2028 where we should kind
of maybe be looking at what we want to do with the new 5-year plan.
Does that include Elizabeth, and is that fully in-house? My recommendation
right now would be to keep Elizabeth on board while we clean up and make
sure that we just get a good clean-running program and getting, you know, good graces
with HUD. So, so of the 20%,
how— is it 50/50 that we're giving Elizabeth, or is it, uh,
like, is all that 20%? Like, I'm just trying to help the,
the council understand because I know this has been a conversation in the past.
Elizabeth, feel free to step in. We're— we are right. We haven't executed
a new contract. We just had a lot of moving parts.
We haven't really had the discussion yet. And so this is a great time to
have the discussion. But Elizabeth, maybe you can speak to your
fees. Absolutely. So I think right now we're
kind of in discussion about what that will look like over the next year or
so. And I am really clear with the communities that
I work with because I work all across the country that I am not a
forever solution. I'm a solution to get through
a period of time. So, you know, if that
is over the next year or over the next 2 years through the rest
of this consolidated plan cycle, then that's fine.
You know, the management of these funds
is tricky. There are a lot of moving parts and there
are There are a lot of restrictions and requirements.
So, you know, this would be something that if you were to manage
this internally, you would want dedicated staff really
working half-time on this activity.
So right now there are some things we're in the middle of
an environmental review monitoring because there were some
challenges there. And HUD is actually— it's not just Equal Opportunity. HUD is Looking
at every program that Meg had managed
over the last number of years, including Lehi,
Orem, and Utah County. So Eagle Mountain has it
the easiest in the sense that they're only going back a couple of years because
the program's new for Eagle Mountain. But some, they're going back
to 2018. So there are some things right now that
really need some concerted effort. and some specialization
to kind of clean up, which I think is where, where I
come in.
Okay, I, uh, is there any questions from the council?
I did, uh, I know the record will reflect this, but welcome
to Council Member Wood too. He was online. Um, I didn't see
him earlier. So, Mayor, this is
Zach, if I could just ask a couple questions. Go ahead.
It's more just for my own understanding of kind of who's
doing what. So we— Kiara, you are a staff
employee of Eagle Mountain City, correct? Yes.
Okay. And you're— are you kind of that half-time
person right now? Kind of trying to be.
And PB&G is in no way, shape, or form fall
under my purview or umbrella, obviously, for housing.
There was just a scenario that I see needed tackling,
and I decided to champion it.
Okay, totally regretted it. So, here we are.
Okay, got it. All right, so we need staff.
And then was it, was it Elizabeth? Yes.
And Elizabeth, could you maybe just share, just so,
just so I kind of understand better, I'm imagining you've
been brought to the table to help us run this program effectively,
kind of train up Kiara. And Kiara is kind of seeing now this is
a pretty big project. And you're training
Kiara and kind of showing her the ropes. And, and can
I ask, what is the fee that you charge and how is that
paid? Is that paid out of these dollars that we're considering, or is it
separate, a separate line item out of our city budget? It's budget neutral.
It's actually paid out of CDBG dollars. So I
charge an hourly rate. I bill in 15-minute increments. I do
have a couple of folks on staff. So, you know,
the tasks that need to be performed, it depends
on what it is. So if we are out, as there had been
some discussion, doing some surveying in town to
define areas that might be eligible for this funding, that's probably
not a great use for my time because I bill higher
than some of my staff does. Okay. I'm, you know, I'm actually,
I do this all over the country. I've worked from Virginia
to Oregon, Ohio to Texas,
so, and lots of states in between.
You know, it's very— go ahead. Yeah, because you've come
to a couple of our council meetings, I thought that maybe you lived in
Utah. I live in Oregon. Okay.
All right. So when you come out, we're basically
paying for flights and travel and your time there.
You're sharing some of that because I also consult with Utah
County. Okay. And so they are actually a larger
client. I have taken on cleaning up an even
bigger mess that was created in the county and
some challenges with HUD. Yeah. So, and I
also do ARPA. I do rescue plan work with Utah County through
the end of this year. So you get economy of scale. I'm already here.
I see. And so you don't have to pay for every flight. You don't have
to pay for every hotel night or every car rental. There's definitely economy
of scale. Okay, thank you. And I believe that people
should be paid what they're, you know, what they're for their time. I'm just more
trying to educate myself. Yes. So what
is that hourly fee? And then how long have we been
working together? And do we have kind of like an annual— we're going through
our budget. I know this is like neutral, but obviously we want to
try and keep as much money in this program as we can.
And, and, you know, if it makes sense for us to task
somebody with a real half-time for this, then we,
as a council, we probably need to consider Who would you train,
or, you know, or things that we could lift off of Kiara's plate so
that she can dedicate more time to this program? Yes.
Okay. So my hourly rate is about $130
an hour. That's fully loaded. And my staff
is anywhere from 65
to about 80. Okay,
great. And how many hours would you say— I
guess, how long have we been working together?
We've been working together just a few months, and we've
just kind of initially started to undertake kind
of the unwinding and building process.
So, you know, it's been A
learning experience for me as I learn what's happened in the past.
And so we're just kind of through that spot.
So it's probably a— you would, would you say it'd be a little bit heavier
here in the first year as we're just like trying to build it up?
And with other cities that you've worked with,
what is that time requirement on your part in your experience?
So it really It varies. I mean, there isn't any
one specific number.
With Utah County, I would probably do somewhere close
to, with expenses, $60,000 to $80,000 each
year. Okay. Outside of the ARPA work that we're doing,
because we have some other rules with them, we do some other federal consulting
work with them. With Eagle Mountain City,
it depends on You know, the tasks that I'm
asked to do, and if I'm training someone, I am— I'm close
enough to retirement that I'm not a long-term solution.
So, you know, and I'm aware of that, and I want
to be very clear about that. I'm not— I'm not a 5-year,
10-year solution. No. I'm a short-term, couple of years,
getting something up and running, training someone.
And I'm retiring. Got it.
That's awesome. Well, I work in the retirement industry, so anytime someone
moves into retirement, I love it. Yeah. Well, well deserved.
So is our load about equivalent to Utah County,
would you say? No. Okay. So we might anticipate $30,000
to $40,000 a year, something like that. Okay. Thank you.
That's, that's kind of what I just wanted to wrap my arms around. Thank you.
Can I actually— I'll submit detailed timesheets for billings
because that's required by 2 CFR 200 federal regulation.
And I do those trainings around the country too.
So I'll submit detailed timesheets. You'll know what I'm doing. Okay. No, no.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, for sure. And then just going— thank you, Elizabeth.
And then maybe just my last question for, for Kiara.
Is this something that You feel like we should
have somebody part-time doing this?
I feel like if we hired somebody part-time, it would be about the same cost
as what we're paying to Elizabeth to kind of manage the program.
Or I guess this
is just like a training opportunity, or are there more things
off of your plate that need to be lifted? I think,
and it's kind of hard to say because it depends on how we,
you know, execute our projects really. If they were all going externally,
and I'm not making a recommendation, I'm just saying if they go externally,
that heavy lift is more so on the organization versus
if we have internal projects like ADA ramps and different things like that,
that requires more internal tracking and compliance.
efforts. Um, and so that doesn't really answer the question. In a
nutshell, I would say yes, there should be a dedicated person to it.
Um, while I'm kind of digesting it all, I think with
my current workload it could work out, it could be fine. Um, Elizabeth's been
great at training, and I'm definitely wrapping my head around other resources that we'll be
able to tap into long term. But, um, yeah,
so it would take— it would take a dedicated person. I don't know what my
role entails of future-wise or what we're looking at as far
as future housing planning or what that looks like as a division
or a department. Um, but yes, it would need dedicated staff.
Thank you. Those are all of my questions, Mayor. Thank you.
Um, Councilmember Wood or Whiting, any questions?
No, I asked my questions, uh, on Tuesday nights.
Yeah, no questions. You guys are good. If there's
no other questions, um, one just to clarification,
you mentioned a public hearing. We already had the public hearing. Yeah, we had that
on last Tuesday. Yeah, so it's just on the notes. I just wanted
to make sure. Um, so if there's no other questions,
um, I'll accept a motion. Mayor, I move that the City Council approve
a resolution of Eagle Mountain City, Utah approving the fiscal
fiscal year 2026 Community Development Block Grant CDBG Annual
Action Plan and authorizing its submission to the U.S.
Department of Housing and Urban Development.
Second. Okay, we have a motion by Councilmember Clark
and a second by Councilmember Wright. Any questions on the motion?
We'll start voting with Councilmember Clark. Yes.
Councilmember Wright. Yes. Councilmember Whiting. Yes.
Councilmember Wood? Yes. Councilmember Huish?
Yes. Okay, that motion passes,
and I will call for another motion. Motion to
adjourn. Oh, second. Okay, Councilmember Wood got the motion.
Good job. Councilmember Clark with a second. All in favor? Aye.
No opposed? Okay, we will adjourn the meeting at
3:00 And, uh, thanks for coming, guys.
Appreciate it. Thank you. Thank you,